broadway legend audra mcdonald she has
won six tonys more than any other
performer in broadway history the emmy
grammy and tony award winner is now
helping to tell the story of another
musical powerhouse the queen of soul
aretha franklin mcdonald plays aretha's
mother in the highly anticipated biopic
respect take a look
how is
[Music]
all right
what about church
praise the lord
[Music]
audra mcdonald wow good morning to you
this movie was amazing thank you so much
for joining us
thank you for having me i'm going to
start with the film you play barbara
aretha's mother and obviously in playing
someone real you have to do the research
for her someone who's no longer alive
what did you learn about her and the
impact that she had on aretha
well sadly she had a very short life you
know she separated from aretha's
father and then she
was living away from her children all
four of her children and then died at
the age of 32 of a sudden heart attack
so it's a very very short tragic life
she had but
she was a pianist she was a singer
mahalia jackson referred to her as one
of the greatest gospel singers of her
day which is kind of amazing that
mahalia jackson knew who aretha
franklin's mother was
um and she was desperate to be with her
children but in those days it was very
you know it was very odd for a father to
be the one to take the children but he
did and so she just worked really hard
to try and get back into her children's
life but never
made it there but had a very close
relationship with aretha in the little
time that they did have together and
shared their love of music and that
really is clear in the movie you talk
about the love of music anyone who even
knows one aretha franklin's song it just
is the soundtrack of that moment you're
in i saw an interview where you said
that you can't remember a time in your
life where aretha franklin's music
wasn't sort of a part of that soundtrack
of your life
no no i don't i i you know i'm gonna go
out on a limb and say probably many
people can't
at least at some point but you know
amazing grace her wonder her amazing
sort of album that came out in 1972 that
was recorded live in the church in in
los angeles i was two years old when
that album came out and i used to play
with the album cover i remember it just
you know booming through our house at
all times i remember when i was in uh
high school and in college listening to
aretha franklin when i was feeling down
and needed to feel up it's just aretha
has always been a soundtrack so to be a
part of this film was a real honor
uh uh it's vlad i i um
the most i've ever been tongue-tied was
when i got a chance to interview aretha
franklin um and when i sadly had to
cover her passing i remember talking to
so many people who expressed just what
you did audra do you remember where you
were when you heard that ms franklin had
passed away
i think i was at home and i knew that
she had been ill and we had heard about
that and then it seemed to like
maybe she was getting better and she
came out and made a statement saying i'm
doing okay
so when she did pass it was it was just
like a part of you went with her
and that it's just like
there was a part of me that's like what
are we going to do aretha franklin's not
here what are we going to do but at the
same time it's like aretha's always
going to be with us
her
her voice and her deep connection
spiritual connection whatever it is
whatever you want to call it where she's
you know somebody reach down from the
heavens and touch those vocal cords and
she has such a connection
um to people when she sings that that
will be with us forever thank goodness
audra it's it's tony the
uh hearing you say that it makes me
wonder what it was like for you on set
to see jennifer hudson bring aretha back
to life for the big screen
it was incredible you know i i was i was
very moved by by jennifer's work in this
film um she sort of for me started to
morph into aretha and the more i thought
about it the more i realized that they
had they they have a lot in common um
they both you know have voices that are
just touched by the heavens they both
have an incredible connection
to the world when they sing you know it
it transcends everything when they sing
and they they both had you know
rough
beginnings they had a lot of things that
they had to um
overcome
and jennifer is the most incredibly
sweet dedicated um lovely person
especially coming out of hollywood that
i've ever met and um
her her ability to inhabit aretha in
this film i thought was uncanny and for
me to be able to watch it up close was
amazing too
just popped out
and i'll let you put it back in and
while you are putting it back in i will
say i know that aretha even chose her to
be in that role which is what's amazing
you also i gotta before we let you go
you were part of the good fight and it's
a show i love watching what has been for
you the most rewarding thing of getting
to play so many different roles that you
have so far
um
well you know the the most wonderful
thing about being
so you're one you know
being an actress is being able to just
sort of
you know inhabit different characters
and
and um and go on different journeys i i
think you begin to understand the human
connection a little bit more and the
human experience the more the more shoes
you walk in and so i i've enjoyed that
um in my career being able to just walk
a lot of different shoes and understand
a lot of different
uh perspectives in life well we enjoy
watching you walk in those shoes
certainly audra mcdonald thank you so
much and the good fight is streaming now
on the viacom cbs streaming service
paramount plus it's a great season trust
me respect in theaters also great today